all right Chris now Chris uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
was born in Hazard Kentucky and I was
raised in Leslie County Kentucky which
is Southeastern and uh the Appalachian
Mountains basically and my my mother she
um she graduated
um Wesley County High School
Valedictorian uh got our scholarship and
went to University of Kentucky
and got a degree in nutrition and health
and it ended up on graduating on in the
dean's list I think and she's a very
soft-spoken woman and very like she's
bashful and shy and I do have that in me
and my dad is the exact opposite and
he uh I remember him telling me a story
of him being like 16 and his mother told
him to go
get a gallon of milk from the store and
he goes and someone pulls up Carlos
pulls up and asks my dad's name is Paul
they called him PF
asked him if he wanted to go and do some
carpentry make money he said yeah so
they go off to Ohio and my dad stays
gone for a year
and ends up saving some money up and
buying a vehicle and coming back and I'm
like did you bring her some milk back
and he's like son I was afraid not to
she's like he's like she she blistered
my behind so
that's my dad and he's very outspoken
and he has no filter which embarrasses
the crap out of me a lot of times but
yeah my dad he ended up dying last year
um
from black long I'm sorry and he's a
coal miner yeah he was a coal miner done
that for years he'd been fighting his
black long for almost 20 years and
about three weeks before he died he
finally got it so it's sort of he done
he he fought for that so that my mother
could live on that because she gets it
and yeah when you say gets it she gets
the benefits
because they were married oh I see like
if she didn't have that she wouldn't be
able to live you know off of what she
would have been drawing but she's good
now how would you describe your
childhood oh man
um my childhood was pretty good I've got
an older sister my dad was married once
before
uh and she lives in Ohio with four
daughters
I got a younger sister with three
daughters and son and a younger brother
with a son and
I think our upbringing was pretty good
we was
um
we was brought up in church and I never
had any abuse of that nature in church
um
and
but like where
where things went bad with me was when
my Mom and Dad would allow me to play
with other children
uh unsupervised pretty much and
and that's where this pretty much takes
a like a dark space with me playing with
other kids and uh specifically there was
an older child that I used to play with
and
or he was around and
um
he would have us watch pornography with
him
and things of that nature and I don't
know if this guy was doing that to sort
of train me to do things or whatever but
that's sort of how it ended up being and
I remember the first porno
that he had us watch
and it was a black dude a white dude
with a woman and I remember it to this
day and I remember as I was six years
old when this
started happening and this would
continue for a couple maybe two or three
years after this but
um
I remember the feeling I had like my
body went numb and and I knew it was
wrong I knew it was wrong but I was very
fixated on that woman and just like
became obsessed with her and the only
way I can describe the feeling is
probably like winning the lottery and
how also having someone put a gun to
your head you know
and
and that started a Gateway in my mind uh
that would you know it it brought a
six-year-old child to become
the Pervert that I became
you know throughout my 20s and early 30s
man I was bad
um
uh
that that abuse did end up stopping one
of the things I regret like I'm not
going to mention names now but one of
the things I regret my life is never say
anything so
I wish I would have said something to my
mother and father and yeah six years old
yes it is and that's you know you
that's where you start developing
your mind
and a lot of people
you know a kid sees his father abuses
mother he'll he'll end up doing that
because that's what he knows at that
time and that's how you you can train a
child to become something good or
something bad
and it it made a pervert out of me
and that's something I regret highly how
did that manifest itself I mean like
when you say a pervert pervert I'm
obsessed on pornography became addicted
to pornography as a child I would like
go to Radio Shack and rip the tags off
of the VHS boxes
and trade them to another video and take
that video home
and I had mom always get a blank tape
and I would trade those and I'd have
like a little softcore porno and that
I'd give them back the blank tape
and um but it also manifested a person
that would obsess on sex
and and and only sex and and just you
know every time I would look like
sitting in high school watching the
girls go by the you know
you know it's like I'll do her did you
see her butt blah blah blah you know you
know I wasn't the only kid doing that
but yeah that was like my mindset at
that time and all through middle school
and even this happened when I was six
six to like eight nine years old so even
in grade school it developed that that
thought process of that's what a woman
is a an object of sexual pleasure
and man it it took over my mind
the picture too drugs did come into the
picture in my early twenties
um
my early 20s I got hooked on some
like lower sets perk sets my one of my
friends he got a car wreck
and broke his femur
and got hooked on methadone
and that was something I played around
with for a while and
um
I'd say around 18 19 years of age I
became addicted to alcohol and
throughout my early 20s I was nothing
but a drunk partying every single
weekend drinking
I got a job in the mines when I was like
20 and
all that money went to nothing but booze
and parties
wasted every this this was where this
was in Leslie County Kentucky where I
grew up coal mining there yes
um
I don't know like coal mining ain't
it's a
unique job
with a lot of rednecks it's it's
basically a bunch of rednecks making fun
of each other
for eight hours playing pranks
things you would not want to even
know happens underground I remember
whenever I first went I had a girlfriend
I dated for six years started in high
school
and first like few weeks
they held me down and sucked a hickey on
my neck and that girl was very jealous
and she was like ready to beat the crap
out of me one day and her dad's like
she's like did they really do that
because her dad works in mines he's like
yeah they do stuff like that so yeah
that's uh that's one of the things that
people's done I've put like
the world's hottest hot sauce and some
drinks of mine because people were
stealing my drinks I've heard people of
there's a guy I worked with he recently
named froggy we called him froggy
someone kept stealing his sandwich
and he ended up putting some froggy
sauce if you know what I mean on that
sandwich that dude ate it and one of the
three people he thought it was was
going up the shaft with him in the
elevator and he and he taught him about
it one of the guys ended up throwing up
on that elevator so that's some of the
stuff that goes on underground and you
know but there's a lot of like brotherly
sisterly love going on like
it's a it's a trip it's been a wild ride
and it's been a beautiful ride actually
I like it yeah okay cool money is kind
of left this area well in 2014 in in
Leslie County 2012 to 14 it started
getting rough
and a guy that I worked with worked in
Morgantown for Peabody and console and
federal two and kept telling me about
the union mines because there's a big
difference between the union Minds and a
non-union coal mine
a non-union coal mine is more like
everybody is helping everybody a union
coal mine you got it's the union versus
them but you're going to get way better
benefits way better pay and
bosses can't make you do you know they
won't make you do things that you
shouldn't do like they do in non-union
but I never had a problem with non-union
but when I came up here
I would have came up here straight out
of high school and got a union job
before I would have went to work down
there because I would have next year if
I got 20 years in I would have had a
pension would have had health care I
could have quit got money right you know
just like
money age moth through the pension like
the health care is like 80 20 for you
and your wife so what West Virginia
treats the coal miners better uh yeah in
terms of in terms of benefits and
retirement that stuff I've got a 401k I
never knew I had so when I got when I
resigned like a month ago
um I checked that and I was like wow so
that that was a plus but I you know I
never fooled with that type of stuff
yeah
you uh you've lived in West Virginia and
Kentucky most of your life yeah I lived
in Kentucky up until 2014 and then I
moved up here to West Virginia in 2014.
um
uh I was married at the time I moved up
here so being addicted to like
pornography and sex I've had bad
relationship problems
um
and they've always ended about the same
so
looking back at everything if your
relationships keep ending
usually the same way it's usually your
fault and you need to look in the mirror
wake up were there other vices that you
were involved in other than drugs and
porn
like I mean just sex I've never been
faithful yeah but not gambling anything
like that well gambling yeah
um I actually around like 2013 I started
playing poker and studying and when we
moved up here
uh uh online gambling was I could do it
up here but not in Kentucky very good
due to the laws and the nature of how
the banks work and whatnot and plus
cryptocurrency started coming out but
yeah
I wanted to become a professional poker
player dude
and I realized like looking back I was
just an addict trying to fulfill a
dopamine rush in my brain because that's
like something I've done from childhood
all the way up to like recent so it's so
I became a lunatic when it came to
gambling when it came to
I have a problem
I can become obsessed with something
that I'm that I enjoy but I won't remain
persistent in it enough
to excel so
I learned so much and then I just wanna
I wanna play get that get that Rush man
and I started playing online poker
and I'd get to the point where I would
like freak out like I would call when I
shouldn't
fold when I shouldn't or go out and like
try to blow up when I shouldn't
and I would like beat the back of my
head until knots would form and I would
like bite myself and pinch myself
because I know better than to do these
things but I do them anyways my wife is
sitting over here freaking out on me and
crying and you know I was obsessed with
money and not trying to be successful I
learned about the law of attraction and
all that good stuff and I was it was all
burned in my head you know
um and
it saw it was like one of the downfalls
of why me and my wife ended up getting
divorced she left me you know I cheated
on her proud of that and with the
ex-girlfriend from like high school that
I dated for six years and
being the Pervert I would record these
things and one day I recorded
or one day I decided to watch one before
I went to work well I forgot to delete
it
come home or I go to work the wife comes
home and finds it
and I'm about an hour from leaving work
it's like almost 11 o'clock man and she
she comes to work
and I'm I get a fun they get a phone
call they said Chris you got to go
outside and the shift Foreman comes up
he gets me and I'm like what's wrong and
I'm thinking oh it's my dad it's my dad
and
get outside man and she's just like her
face is just as red as her hair and
she's a beautiful redheaded freckled
face chick you're right and I'm like
what's wrong
and she couldn't really speak and she
just turns around and walks out and I'm
like oh man I know what's wrong now
so I walk out after and it's like a
beautiful night and the snow is just
falling down slowly
and she goes up to the back of her
vehicle man and she turns around and she
said who is she
and I tell her who she is and she just
starts wailing on my face
and I'm thinking
you deserve more than whatever she's
going to do to you you better not hurt
her and the only thing I could do was
stand there with my hands behind my back
and let her beat the crap out me man
and she busted my nose my lip and I
still got a tooth chip from it man you
let her do it
yeah I'm gonna yeah I deserved every bit
of it every bit of it
and that's one of the things that I've
that you know I have to learn from that
I can't I can't let I can't treat the
next woman I'm with the way I treated
her I have to learn from that
you know because one of my biggest
regrets in life is how I'm how bad that
I must have made that woman feel you
know my heart dropped
whenever I I knew I messed up and got
caught but it's a good thing I got
caught
but I can't imagine how far her heart
dropped whenever she seen that video
and man you know that's one of the
biggest things that hurts me looking
back on my life is how I treated that
that woman and
and you know we ended up you know our
divorce and everything went we ended up
parting somewhat on good terms
and you know sometimes you know
messenger and stuff
about my life and you know but
it's uh it's it's a wild ride you made
some mistakes oh yeah I've made a bunch
of mistakes in terms of that
um
is it just the
the adrenaline rush that I don't know I
think it's the dopamine Rush
um
I actually but I actually got into
skydiving for about four months
and that's one of the amazing most
amazing experiences I've ever had
but yeah it's it's it is a huge rush I'm
addicted to anything that gives me that
Rush right now I'm like one of my only
joys in life is rock climbing so rock
climbing is something I love to do and
that scares me more than going up in an
airplane and jumping out because you're
dangling there harms the feet above the
the Earth and you know it'd be great
rock climbing here
we have New River gorgeous is probably
the best rock climbing
on the East Coast
right here in the state of West Virginia
man it's beautiful you're so growing up
in Kentucky and West Virginia you're
growing up an Appalachia you saw a lot
of friends that were involved in drugs
well if you want to go to Leslie County
right now about the only thing to do
there is meth
so yeah like all the people I graduated
with a lot of them ended up
ended up on drugs ended up on like back
in the early 2000s it was all about
pills then they started you know going
away from that but like now most people
was on methadone but now they've got
Suboxone clinics everywhere and those
people were just going to run into the
Suboxone Clinic getting their fix
you know and and now meth has hit and
meth is like
it's like a it's a scary drug it is a
scary drug people here are smoking it
yeah most mostly they're smoking and
um
it's something if you do you're going to
stay up
days upon days man and it's a
it's a lot of people end up like yeah
it's a constrictant just like cocaine is
my drug is cocaine but meth is like
they're both constrictants but
so when you do them a lot of the times
men can't you know get an erection
but being me being addicted to porn and
sex the only thing I can think about
when I'm doing these drugs is porn or
sex and
it's a lot of people that's the only
thing that they end up doing for days is
like watching porn or trying to have sex
and uh yeah it's uh
it's it with with math
when you come off it
you start experiencing psychosis
and I had an experience I didn't know
that that existed but the last time I
did it was
Thanksgiving of last year 2002. and I
was doing it for like four days and I
came off of it
got my sleep in drove back home to West
Virginia
got home the electric was out
so I laid down and I start hearing
people
and two weeks before that I got robbed
so in my mind they're trying to rob me
again
and this is this fuel this hearing these
people it sounds like they're really
there it doesn't sound like it's
happening in your head but I think what
it is is the vibration of sounds is what
may is is making it in your mind it's
making you think it's actually saying
something
but because I kept hearing something
through like the vents or whatever in
the bait in the garage my house is above
a garage so
I think that these people are trying to
steal something from me so I get my gun
and I'm sitting there for about 30
minutes and I'm hearing two women and
two men saying things and I hear them
outside my car so I hit the panic button
and then I turn it off and in my mind
I'm thinking some chick is like oh now
he's we're going to kill him we have to
kill him we gotta kill this guy
so I call 9-1-1 man I'm like yo I think
I'm being robbed right so basically I'm
geeking out or whatever experiencing
psychosis an after effect of coming off
of meth and
three cops show up sweep the area we
don't we don't we haven't found anything
we don't see nobody I was like okay well
all right I was like I ain't staying
here tonight so I shut the door and for
the next four to five nights
I go to Walmart parking lot and sleep in
my car after work because I'm hearing
that mind you I work Underground
and although I went High I'm here in
psychosis and there's always
ventilation in the minds
and I go what I do or did was Fireball
so I would examine seals and things
and I would be back there by myself
scared to death because like usually
you'll sit down for like five minutes or
15 minutes and rest a little bit and
then get up and walk like because I'm
duck walking all the time and crawling
I didn't stop I did not stop when I went
back in those places didn't stop the
whole shift
why do you think it is that so many
people in this part of the country are
into drugs
oh well in Leslie County there's nothing
to do there's the only thing to do there
is probably ride four-wheelers but I
mean it's some of the most beautiful
part of it it is it is beautiful it is
beautiful when I grew up we had
entertainment we had fugit's
entertainment center
I got a video on YouTube uh going
walking through the
the old water park at fugates they
burned it down they burned the cinema
down I guess the guy that created all
that without a bowling alley a cinema
skating rink water park dad's like two
theaters there
um in Hazard so in Leslie County there's
nothing there's a couple dollar stores
so people just get bored I think people
it's like the the experiment they had
with the rat in the Box
keep the rat in the Box by itself have
water and have water with cocaine in it
he's always going to that you give him
something to do friends found like
friends and rat you know a girlfriend
and whatnot
he's going to the water he's you know
skipping that and you know
a lot of people that rock climb that I
that I hang out with are former at my
one of my best friends Raj she's a
former addict and uh he's been clean for
like six years now uh when I was going
through my thing with the cocaine man he
was trying to help me and
eventually I lost my job because of a
drug test and one of the best things
that he he did was he said he said Chris
get clean get sober I mean you can hang
out again and go rock climbing and a lot
of people have friends that are more
like
they're not that way they'll be like oh
it's all right you know but
uh NF has a song and it's a in one of
the bars in his songs is surround
yourself with people that challenge how
you think not those that not their head
and act like they agree
and I needed that from that person to
say we can't hang out until you get
clean and sober I appreciate that for
him you know
um your life is
turning for the better though
well yeah I mean uh well I was very
depressed since my dad died you know and
getting hooked on coke and everything
I've been depressed and lonely
and very depressed at work I've I
switched portals and I've never been
written up in my life and here I am
getting rid of I got wrote up in like
three times in three months dude
and I was just like depressed
and once and I knew that I would
eventually get drug tested and fi you
know I resigned but you know basically I
would have got fired
um I knew that would happen but
and I knew I figured you know I figured
my life's gonna turn upside down and
this and that but things are going on
right now that I that I didn't know I
didn't know about like
money put in a 401k that that I had so
now I have enough money to buy the house
that I'm living in
and my mom said she would have me out
until I get a job and my landlord he's
like a friend to me uh he's helping me
out with a job so
things aren't bad plus I have friends in
Kentucky I got a friend in Kentucky that
builds houses from the ground up he said
man come back here you can work here
you know
help me out and that I think that would
help me a lot because I would be near
family
so I may go back to Kentucky and and
work with him for a while at least until
I get my car back I don't know I don't
know really if I really want to go back
to coal mining or not
it's been good to me
but all the fun days are over like the
fun times was back in the early 2000s it
got pretty serious around 2009 to 12.
with emsa and laws rules regulations and
things of that nature yeah you're lucky
you have some good friends and family
yeah my family is the best man my nieces
and nephew love me
and a few years ago I was going through
some things and Emma J and Aaliyah and
Jonathan Tyler they're like
they're probably the reason I didn't
take a gun and blow my brains out
and I appreciate them a lot they're
they're the world to me
and Willow it's another niece of mine
what's your biggest regret in all of
this
probably not not mentioning what
happened to me as a kid to my family
um
and the way I treated my ex-wife really
that's probably the biggest regrets not
not trying not understanding addiction
at early age I thought sex addiction was
good it's natural
but it's it can it can hurt you your
family and others man mental mentally
you know
and
yeah that's uh it's a bad thing
it's just as bad as any other addiction
really
yeah what would you say the biggest
lesson you've
learn from all of this
is
forgiveness
um my well indirectly a few people have
helped me with forgiveness
um first I I believe the Bible is the
word of God
so I'm not religious that Bible rip
religion apart um Paul Lucas has a video
called religion being religious
and not being dispensational is
dangerous and I recommend anybody to
watch that it helped me seven like last
July I watched that and it's it's
changed my life because it's broken the
religion up that you know that I might
have been following
and I take the book literal now
in terms of forgiveness and things like
Joe Rogan helped me indirectly by
talking about sensory deprivation tanks
I started laying in those and meditating
helped me a lot my old therapist Bob
Edmondson man he uh
I had problem because when I would
recall these memories he's like Chris
you can't
have a 30 year old brain in that
six-year-old body going through these
things that way because you're not
you're you're six you're a child
and you gotta you gotta understand that
and Evan Jarvis and an old poker coach
of mine man he uh he taught me about you
know you gotta learn how to forgive
yourself
and he said he uh
showed me a exercise to do
about it's a mental exercise and
basically you close your eyes
and the person you are now go back to
the person that you hate because trust
me if you've hated me I've hated myself
worse
and like
mid-20s early 20s Chris you know I've
got to go back I today have to go back
to him
and learn to forgive him and hug him and
say I'm you don't understand the things
you're doing
you know and forgive myself
and
you know forgiveness is that and I want
to say this to that specific person who
has who did this abuse to me it was
multiple I forgive you I love you and
before you die I hope you're found in
the body of Christ I hope I see you all
in heaven that's what I'm that's what I
truly want I you know and if I've hurt
someone mentally
in some way you know I want forgiveness
too
I apologize
so forgiveness is probably the biggest
thing that's great learn to forgive
all right Chris thank you so much for
sharing your story yes sir thank you so
much for having me I wish you all the
luck in the world down here